hi it's Michele from lab - beauty
science chemistry PhD and earn out of
some acne prone skin I have oily skin
and that usually goes hand-in-hand with
acne so today I'm going to be giving you
my top five tips for acne prone skin if
you like the sort of video give it a
thumbs up subscribe to my channel and
click the notification bell so you don't
miss any videos a bit of background
about my skin it's always been quite
acne prone and oily because of genetics
and it's been this way since I was about
13 which is 18 years ago
as I learn more about skincare I helped
my skin improve because if you look
after it well that does get rid of a lot
of the issues but it can't get rid of
everything so for example I still have
hormonal acne which is much harder to
treat with topical treatments and
generally you'll need to take
medications for it
I did take the combined oral
contraceptive pill for a while and my
skin got better but it had other side
effects that I wasn't entirely happy
with and so I'm currently not using it
my skin is still so much better than it
was before so here are the five best
tips I have all of these are in part
science-based but some of these are
mostly just practical my first tip is to
use the gentle cleanser when I first
started having acne in the early 2000s
as a 13 year old my dad bought me a
menthol cleanser from Avon which had
pointy microplastics scrubbing bits
it was bright blue and it made me feel
like I could really scrub away the dirt
Payne is my friend
I deserve this
as I started buying my own skincare
products I tended to use brands like
clean and clear and Proactiv which have
really dry and cleanses and scrubs and
alcohol-based toners that's done my face
and that made it feel really effective
because it hurt and because it must be
hurting it must be hurting the bacteria
even more this is one of the big myths
about skincare and luckily it seems to
be going away but in reality hurting
yourself is not really a good idea dirty
skin is not one of the main causes of
acne it can exacerbate acne but gentle
cleansing is enough cleansing your skin
too harshly leads to inflammation and
irritation which also contributes to
acne and it doesn't let your skin
recover high ph cleansers and constantly
disturbing your skin with cleansing
makes it easier for acne bacteria to
spread and get a foothold on your skin
gentle cleanser also made my skin less
dehydrated which made it feel less oily
as well and if you want to find out more
about how to choose and use a gentle
cleanser you can check out the lab mufin
guide to basic skin care which goes
through how to build a routine from
scratch tip number 2 for acne prone skin
is to limit your access to mirrors I
found out one of my worst habits which I
still have is picking up my spots and
having prolonged picking sessions
picking out your spots makes your
irritation worse and if you pick too
hard you end up with scarring
I found myself scrutinizing my skin and
picking out spots that were barely spots
I was speaking at spots that weren't
ready I was pulling off loose skin
flakes when I was in my early 20s I went
on a trip with my family to Hong Kong
and I stayed at a hotel where I didn't
have any mirrors near me and I found
that my skin managed to recover a whole
heap at that time I used to have a
really flaking dry constantly irritated
nose and it completely recovered during
this trip simply because I wasn't
constantly irritating it and so when I
got home I decided I would get rid of
any mirrors that were in my study area
so if you are also really prone to
picking at your spots continuously like
me it really helps if you get rid of
mirrors near where you procrastinate so
perhaps where you study you can limit
yourself to picking in the bathroom for
example or after a shower so my way
you're not just
gonna stay there for ages my next tip is
on how you should squeeze a pimple some
people think that you should never
squeeze spots but I personally find that
extracting it is sometimes better than
leaving it alone but only if you do it
right and that means gently firstly you
need to make sure it's hygienic if not
then you're really just making extra
bacteria go in it goes deeper it invades
the rest of your skin and it spreads the
infection you want to limit the damage
so make sure you don't squeeze that
until it's actually ready to be squeezed
if your spots aren't quite ready to be
squeezed it's best to leave them and
just exfoliate and your skin should be
able to get rid of them on its own so if
you're going to squeeze a pimple it's
best if you have clean hands if you
clean your face first if you wrap your
nails with tissue or use cotton buds and
if you Lance the pimple so you stick a
needle in it so that there's a space for
the pus to escape before you squeeze it
so will come out the right way instead
of going deeper into the skin my fourth
tip for acne prone skin is to change
your pillowcase regularly and this is
especially the case if you aren't
sleeping on your back there's a few
different reasons for this firstly oil
from skin on your face bacteria and
sebum all of this stuff ends up on your
pillow and this is all comedogenic this
will slowly oxidize with the air and
alternate to self that's even more
committed genic if you use hair
conditioner it contains lots of
ingredients that tend to break people
out so changing your pillowcase can stop
this from pressing into your face every
night and keep in mind that you sleep
for about eight hours a day which is a
third of your life so some people change
their pillowcases every night or every
few days or once a week depending on how
sensitive your skin is to this stuff so
it's worth just trying to change your
pillowcase more often and see if this
makes a difference my fifth and final
tip for this video is to look at using
some anti acne actives
there are four main factors that lead to
acne and they are inflammation clogged
pores bacteria and excess oil so you're
looking for actives that target these
four things firstly you can try some
exfoliant so you can try some gentle
physical exfoliants and chemical
exfoliants and so these gentle exfoliant
will help you get rid of clogged pores
without causing too much inflammation if
you're interested in finding out more I
have a video on exfoliation and a free
exfoliation guide that you can download
another really effective anti acne
ingredient is benzoyl peroxide and this
can be a little bit irritating though if
your skin is prone to that so just use
it with caution you can also look at
using of retinoid in your routine which
is a vitamin a derivative some of these
are available over-the-counter so for
example different and rational you can
also get some with a prescription so for
example at rationale if your acne is a
bit more severe so if it's a bit deeper
then you can also look at using some
oral medications so for example
isotretinoin which is also called
accutane spironolactone and also the
oral contraceptive pill so if you want
to look more into that talk to your
doctor if you want more tips on how to
deal with hyperpigmentation after the
acne is gone then you can also check out
my hyperpigmentation routine I hope you
liked this video and found it useful if
you did give it a thumbs up and you can
also subscribe to my channel for more
videos like this you can also follow me
on instagram at lab muffin beauty
science and you can check out my blog
for more nerding out about beauty
see you next time